[Music]  I've been waiting to kiss her for like  20 years man Fred all right wait I just  don't know when the time will be right I  don't want to rush it because I know  that that kiss will be a sign if we're  meant to be together or for not I'm a  man I'm not a boy anymore and I hope  that she sees that as well so how are  you I'm taking this like extremely  seriously I just want to ask is this a  time that you feel that I can can't kiss  you you're asking wonder caste I'm gonna  ask you because I want you to feel  comfortable  well now that's not so awkward good  because I've never had anybody ask me  they just do it right but listen listen  if I just do it I want you to know  I want you to know and she might feel  something okay  you